- Snapchat. Here's what people
have to understand.
I predict, I'm going hard core here.
I predict in 2016 that Snapchat
will have a number 1, 2 or 3 spot
in the most important apps
in the world from the
13 to 40, let me say it again,
40 year-old sector.
Maybe even 45. 50.
That the 25 to 50 year-old
sector on Snapchat in 2016
is going to blow away the
far majority of people
watching this episode.
And so, let me give you a fun
fact on how to get good at it
or start playing with it.
The one big creative play that
I see on Snapchat that makes
it so different is the notion of
taking a picture and
then drawing on top of it.
Some of you who follow me
have seen the things.
The weird spider, the rain drops.
I'm starting to play
with it a little bit.
I'm a big fan of that.
It opens up enormous creativity.
Enormous. Oh, DRock some
of my funny Snaps.
I don't know where you're
putting them DRock but
and so I'll give
you those images.
If you're a winery,
take pictures in the wine room,
in the vineyard, of the bottle
and then draw
creative things around it.
I do think that people
will enjoy that.
It'll be a little ha-ha.
You can do some
little contest by running in.
I think drawing on
top of the images
because the images on
Instagram, Facebook and Twitter
they all look the same.
This drawing thing is a
real creative variable.
It is a difference maker.
The attention's on Snapchat.
I am bullish on that ghost.